tu sais quand tu ressens que
je fais ça depuis 20 ans je n'ai jamais eu une
telle sensation tu vas voir
exactement ce que je vois c'est de quelle
grandeur j'ai besoin la plus grande chaussure de basket
qui ait jamais été faite quel est le
plan nous  construire une ligne de chaussures autour de
lui pour une recrue qui n'a jamais mis les pieds sur
un terrain de la NBA qui est un joueur
Michael Jordan
Michael Jordan Je pense tendre la
main aux parents tu as parlé
directement à la famille tu vas
perdre ton  travail est-ce que vous vous présentez généralement
aux portes d'entrée des gens à l'improviste on
m'a dit de ne pas appeler oh mec on y va
de temps en temps
quelqu'un arrive c'est si
extraordinaire que cela force le changement
parce qu'ils sont si spéciaux une chaussure
n'est qu'un navire jusqu'à  mon fils y entre,
nous
avons fait une exclusivité dans les salles le 5 avril